[Musique]
deux chiens ces calculs et je vous jure
je devais en répétition c'est incroyable
capucine va devoir relever le défi
d'aller plus vite sans se tromper c'est
possible capucines dans des additions
démultiplication et des divisions en ont
assez assis ya pas de soustraction et
puis quoi encore s'il y en a aussi
alors j'en vois rien pour un bon c'est
toujours très compliqué donc en combien
de temps on va faire 4 prédation quatre
opérations
le premier guide le résultat marque un
point d'accord tout est clair
ouais alors à votre avis nos amis qui va
compter le plus vite
le champion le chienchien le chien a non
plus j'ai déjà belle isabelle je vois
pas la peine capitale
alors voilà il ya un côté qui pensent
que c'est le champion qu'est zimeray
gemmerlé un chien il va gagner tu vas
gagner sa percée dans cette course à son
pupitre
attention vous êtes mon téléphone sinon
on va dire que je triche nombreuses
façons alors oui il faudrait arriver là
attention seulement nous première
opération attention concentrez vous
endettez au poil on y va 21
divisez d'accord ok j'entends rien jeudi
par l'express
bon alors allez-y dites le à l'échangé
avait donc vallonné 21 / 7 + 3
[Applaudissements]
c'est chaud la rapidité j'avais mal tant
décriée ces deux têtes et le chien est
plus rapide
non la toile oui mais attention 1-0 pour
lui c'est la tête
sa tension à wimbledon l'opération
attention je ne dis pas pourquoi pas
tomber le chien on y va ouais je me
montre une autre tchèque à la caméra 9 /
trois plus trois jeunes
[Musique]
alors je suis en train de réfléchir
quand même parce que j'ai dit que si tu
perds des cours princières savait faire
quelque chose mais même temps tu connais
pas la réponse du tout moi ou quoi
allez celle du niveau 2 du cm1 seront
vite il a mois avant que c'est un chien
mais il a mois avant de finir oui mais
il est malhonnête copine attention
troisième opération bord dit je te kiffe
on y va on y va
20 / 2 - 9 plus jeunes 4
et ça fait 2 pourquoi tant la diva n'est
pas bon et puis façon et babouche et
capucine tu as perdu ta pourquoi ben on
a fait trop d'opérations à tadic
ah bah oui
juste pour le plaisir je suis en plein
sahara et moi j'aime bien on va sauver
une petite dernière punaise je kiffe ce
chien c'est comment il s'agit d' une
condamnation et une dernière machine
c'est pour l'honneur voulait marquer un
point
bizarre bizarre on n'y va pas concentré
à la rive de gier
dit rien cette fois 4 / 2010 cette fois
qu'un confiance à faire non allez c'est
trop s'est tramé par invité il s'est
trompé
cette fois visé par deux moins de 10 14
à 14 heures plus chére via mon nom il a
fait il est à détroit quand même saison
4 bravo mon bonjour merci j'ai vraiment
dit
enfin djoko
bravo
alors leur aller